all right Politico is now reporting that
House Republicans are just weeks away
from deciding whether to file formal
articles of impeachment against
President Joe Biden there are just a few
more interviews that need to happen
first including one of Hunter himself
and Hunter has a lot of questions to
answer like who is buying his art what
are they getting in return Why has a
big-time Democrat Party donor and
Hollywood lawyer given Hunter Biden so
much money and paid off his massive tax
liability and what about that 10% for
the big guy here now with an update on
the Biden family investigations is house
oversight committee chairman James comr
good evening uh Mr chairman you've got
uh one very important witness coming up
what do you expect to hear from
him well we have a lot of questions you
mentioned several of them obviously uh
we're very concerned about the millions
of dollars that he and his family have
received from our enemies around the
world we're concerned that it appears
that at least 20 of his llc's appear to
be nothing more than shell companies
that were set up to receive wires from
foreign Nationals and to deceive the IRS
uh in paying taxes uh we're concerned
about what level of involvement Joe
Biden had uh in these business schemes
that the bidens were clearly involved in
we want to know uh exactly what uh role
Joe played and why Joe's been so
dishonest with the American people about
his knowledge and invol excuse me
Congressman do you really expect Hunter
Biden to give you an answer regarding
what his father and how his father was
involved given the fact that his father
has told the American people I had
nothing to do with his
business yeah I mean look Hunter Biden
went along with a narrative that his
laptop uh was Russian disinformation
that it wasn't his all along and now we
know he's suing the laptop repair guy
for disclosing his laptop so you know
the the the president's son has been all
over the board much like the president
uh but now he's going to have an
opportunity to clear his good name and
if I were Hunter Biden I would want to
come in front of the house oversight
committee and answer our questions if
he's done nothing wrong then uh then he
can go and defend his good name and and
uh live happily ever after all right but
you know Congressman it's it's very
interesting Mr chairman I should call
you it's very interesting though don't
we have sufficient evidence we've got
people like Devin Archer we've got
people like Tony balinski we've got
emails we've got photographs we've got
evidence I mean as a former prosecutor
myself irrespective of what Hunter says
you've got a clearly pra fascia Cas here
y i I think so I've said that for many
months I think we've produced many
smoking guns and there are people in the
mainstream media that want to say
otherwise but poll after poll comes out
and shows that the American people are
keeping up with this investigation and
they realize that uh something bad is
going on here and the president of the
United States has been dishonest uh with
the American people he's lied at least a
dozen times about who he met with and
what level of involvement he had in his
his family's criminal activities and
that's what they are we're talking about
moneya laundering we're talking about
tax evasion we're talking about
Securities fraud and the list goes on
and on and on so uh these are very
serious crimes that any other American
would have already gone to prison over
so so really there are two things that
uh the Congress is going to have to look
at here with respect to Biden corruption
first of all is the corruption itself
and secondly is the government cover up
and and you know the witness that J Joe
that Jim Jordan subed uh Leslie wolf we
have a lot of questions for her because
her name always pops up anytime there's
an obstruction anytime that uh we
interview a government employee that was
supposed to be investigating this and
they say they were told to stand down
all roads lead to to the Leslie wolf so
we have a lot of questions for her and I
know Jim Jordan's going to do a very
good job in that deposition but the
bidens will come in front of our
committee uh we expect them to if they
do not uh Congress will hold them
accountable and I think that the
evidence is overwhelming and I know
there are two or three moderates that
that still want to see what the bidens
have to say in their depositions but at
that point the the whole conference will
get together and and we'll decide how
we're going to hold this family
accountable for wrongdoing okay okay so
when it when it comes to a a vote on
whether or not you're going to impeach
Joe Biden when do you think that's going
to
happen well certainly uh that'll be
probably early spring you know the
sooner the better uh it just depends on
when these people come in for the for
the depositions and transcribed
interviews uh we have about 24 people
that we want to hear from and we're
expecting to to hear from them in the
next 45 days uh after we hear from them
hopefully we'll be able to wrap up our
job on the oversight committee which was
to investigate criminal wrongdoing and
and issue a report then we'll hand it
off to the Judiciary Committee right but
when you said you're going to hold them
accountable if they make a decision to
not come will you hold them in
contempt absolutely that's something
that Jim Jordan and I talked with uh
speaker Johnson at length about last
week and I think we're all on board we
expect uh we expect people to to respect
our subpoenas this has been a credible
investigation we've been very
transparent this is a legitimate
committee unlike the January 6th
committee this is a committee where both
parties appointed their membership uh we
have you know published four Bank
memorandums we've had countless press
conferences I don't know how many
interviews we've done we've been
transparent with the American people lot
you have done an awful lot look final
question that I have we talked about a
lot of bank accounts a lot of different
banks have you gotten all the bank
records that you would want
to just about I think one thing that's
hard for anyone to understand is how
many different accounts right the
Biden's had with each one of these shell
companies we continue to find new
accounts almost on a on a weekly Bas we
find a new account the Biden's had so
they're still coming in but we've had
very good luck with the banks the banks
have done a pretty good job honoring our
subpoenas all right chairman comr thank
you so much and Happy Thanksgiving to
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else